Les asiatiques ne tiennent pas l'alcool.
Ouais, alors, dit comme ça, ça ressemble
à un bon gros vieux cliché occidental,
et pourtant il y a quand même une forme de
réalité physiologique derrière.
Chez beaucoup de personnes et notamment
en Chine, en Corée ou au Japon,
il existe une forme d'intolérance à
l'alcool, alors comment ça se fait?
Est-ce que c'est une maladie,
est-ce que certains asiatiques ont
un défaut génétique
qui les rend intolérants à l'alcool,
alors que les occidentaux auraient
de meilleurs gènes?
Eh ben, pas vraiment et en fait ça serait
même plutôt le contraire.
Alors pour comprendre tout ça,
commençons par regarder d'où vient
l'alcool que l'on consomme.
Ce qu'on appelle alcool dans
le langage courant,
ça correspond essentiellement
à une molécule: l'éthanol.
L'éthanol est produit par certains
microorganismes,
selon un procédé qu'on appelle
la fermentation alcoolique.
Dans cette réaction chimique, des levures,
qui sont des champignons unicellulaires,
sont capables de transformer le glucose
en alcool,
selon la réaction suivante: une molécule
de glucose donne
deux molécules d'éthanol et deux molécules
de dioxyde de carbone.
Pour les levures, cette réaction,
c'est d'abord
un moyen de produire de l'énergie
et l'éthanol,
c'est finalement juste un déchet de ce
métabolisme.
Ici on parle de métabolisme anaérobie
car la fermentation alcoolique
n'a pas besoin d'apport d'oxygène.
Ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que,
pour les levures
la fermentation alcoolique c'est plutôt
le plan B pour trouver l'énergie.
Le plan A c'est souvent une forme de
respiration cellulaire
qui est presque 20 fois plus efficace
que la fermentation alcoolique,
mais qui nécessite de l'oxygène.
C'est quand on les prive d'oxygène
que les levures active le plan B
et se mettent à faire de la fermentation
alcoolique.
C'est d'ailleurs un truc qu'avait
découvert Pasteur:
si on fournit de l'oxygène à des levures,
eh bien la fermentation alcoolique cesse.
C'est donc ça qui explique que les boissons
alcoolisées
que l'on consomme soient produites
au moyen de levure
à partir de fruits ou de céréales
qui sont des sources de glucides.
Les effets de la consommation d'alcool
sur nos organismes, on les connaît:
Ça a un impact sur l'humeur, le comportement
et les capacités motrices et cognitives,
le mouvement, la mémoire, le raisonnement etc.
Mais pourquoi l'éthanol fait ça, par
quels mécanismes?
Eh bien les molécules d'éthanol
qui atteignent notre cerveau
vont interférer avec le fonctionnement
de certains neurotransmetteurs.
Les neurotransmetteurs ce sont de petites
molécules
qui sont libérées par les neurones
pour servir de mode de communication
avec d'autres neurones,
et leur fonctionnement normal, eh bien
c'est d'aller
activer des récepteurs en se fixant dessus,
et bien qu'on ne comprenne pas tout
de l'impact physiologique de l'éthanol,
on sait qu'il peut se fixer sur certains
récepteurs
et ainsi perturber une partie
des communications cérébrales
ce qui provoque l'altération de notre
comportement et de nos capacités.
Alors, heureusement pour nous, les effets
de l'alcool ne sont pas permanents,
notre organisme sait éliminer l'éthanol,
notre corps possède en effet
une famille d'enzymes
nommées ADH pour: alcool déshydrogénase,
qui servent justement à décomposer l'alcool
et ça se passe essentiellement dans le foie.
À première vue on peut se dire que
c'est bizarre l'existence de cette enzyme.
Le fait de boire de l'alcool c'est
quand même un truc pas du tout naturel,
c'est spécifique de l'être humain et c'est
très récent à l'échelle de notre espèce.
Comment ça se fait qu'on a pile les enzymes
qui permettent de décomposer l'éthanol?
Eh bien la raison pourrait justement
être assez ancienne.
En 2000 le biologiste Robert Dudley
a proposé l'hypothèse suivante:
la capacité à métaboliser l'alcool pourrait
être apparue chez les primates
il y a plusieurs millions d'années,
comme un moyen d'accès à de nouvelles
sources d'alimentation.
En effet il n'est pas rare que certains
fruits trop mûrs ou tombés au sol,
soient naturellement le siège
d'une fermentation alcoolique
par des levures, et donc la capacité
à dégrader l'alcool aurait pu être favorisée
par l'évolution chez les primates
qui se nourrissaient de fruits.
À l'appui de cette hypothèse, une étude
parue en 2014 a montré
qu'une mutation de l'enzyme ADH4
serait apparue
il y a environ 10 millions d'années
chez un ancêtre commun des humains,
des gorilles et des chimpanzés.
Cette mutation rendrait l'enzyme ADH4
40 fois plus efficace
et pourrait être une des raisons de
la capacité que nous avons
à métaboliser l'alcool, et elle aurait fourni
à nos ancêtres
un avantage évolutif, en leur permettant de
consommer des fruits fermentés.
Si on croit cette thèse, la capacité à
métaboliser l'alcool
ne serait pas apparue parce que les sociétés
humaines fabriquent
et consomment des boissons alcoolisées,
mais elle daterait d'il y à bien
plus longtemps.
On appelle parfois cette idée
"l'hypothèse du singe ivre",
mais si cette hypothèse est correcte,
il y a quand même un truc bizarre,
pourquoi certains d'entre nous semblent avoir
une intolérance à l'alcool?
Genre ils n'ont pas évolué comme les autres
ou ils ont une sorte de maladie génétique?
Alors examinons de plus près ce phénomène.
On sait que chez certaines personnes,
la consommation même d'une faible
quantité d'alcool provoque rapidement
un certain nombre de troubles, des nausées,
des maux de tête, des vomissements,
et l'apparition de rougeurs qu'on appelle
parfois
le syndrome du rougissement asiatique
"l'asian flush" en anglais
et on connaît assez bien l'origine
de ce phénomène,
pour le comprendre, on va revenir
sur la manière dont l'alcool est métabolisé,
je vous ai parlé des enzymes ADH
qui vont dégrader l'éthanol,
plus précisément elles vont le transformer
en acétaldéhyde,
et les molécules d'acétaldéhyde seront,
à leur tour, transformées en acétate
par une autre enzyme: l'ALDH et l'acétate
est ensuite facilement éliminé.
Le point essentiel, c'est qu'il y a
deux étapes
et que c'est en fait l'acétaldéhyde,
le produit intermédiaire,
qui provoque les nausées, le rougissement
et tous les symptômes associés,
or il existe deux circonstances
qui vont provoquer
une augmentation importante des taux
d'acétaldéhyde,
certaines personnes possèdent une mutation
de l'enzyme ADH
qui la rend particulièrement efficace
et comme elle est plus efficace, eh bien
elle produit plus vite l'acétaldéhyde,
mais il existe également une mutation
de l'enzyme ALDH
qui elle, la rend moins efficace,
donc l'acétaldéhyde qui s'accumule est
moins bien éliminé.
Si une personne subit l'un
de ces deux phénomènes
ou même la combinaison des deux, eh bien
quand elle va consommer de l'alcool,
elle va se taper un pic d'acétaldéhyde
dans son corps
et ça va provoquer tous les effets associés
au syndrome du rougissement asiatiques,
et l'effet peut être assez énorme,
dans une étude parue en 2014
qui a été réalisée en Corée du Sud,
il a été mesuré
que ceux qui avaient à la fois l'une
et l'autre des mutations
pouvaient avoir des pics d'acétaldéhyde
dans le sang
dix fois plus importants que les autres,
pour une même quantité d'alcool
ingérée au départ,
et comme vous l'aurez deviné, ces mutations
touchent particulièrement
les personnes originaires
du Nord-Est asiatique.
Alors on va regarder les chiffres, et pour ça
rappelez vous une chose:
pour chacun de nos gènes nous possédons
deux copies,
donc pour chacune des enzymes on peut
n'avoir aucune des deux copies mutées
ou bien une qui est mutée ou bien
carrément les deux,
donc je vais noter les mutations
avec des étoiles,
d'après une revue de la "Littérature"
parue en 2007,
les Chinois et les Taïwanais seraient 90%
à avoir au moins une mutation de l'ADH
avec même la double mutation pour la
moitié d'entre eux
et ils seraient un bon tiers à avoir
au moins une mutation de l'ALDH,
chez les Japonais on serait à des valeurs
même un peu plus élevées
et chez les Coréens un tout petit peu moins,
mais si on regarde par exemple les Indiens,
eh bien le tableau est assez différent,
autour de 15% pour les mutations de l'ADH
et quelques % seulement pour l'ALDH,
chez les personnes d'origine européenne
ou africaine,
ces mutations peuvent exister aussi mais
avec des taux encore plus faible,
et ça explique pourquoi cette forme
d'intolérance à l'alcool dont on a parlé
semble principalement exister chez celles
et ceux ayant des origines en Asie orientale.
Mais pourquoi ils seraient différents?
Pourquoi une telle présence
de ces mutations?
On a vu que la capacité à métaboliser
l'alcool daterait
d'un ancêtre commun des gorilles,
des chimpanzés et des humains,
donc bien avant l'apparition d'homo
sapiens,
ça veut dire que ces mutations
sont apparues bien après,
c'est comme si certaines populations
asiatiques avaient perdu
la capacité à métaboliser l'alcool.
Ce qui est bizarre, c'est que si c'était
juste une sorte de défaut génétique
ça devrait rester un phénomène
assez rare.
Pourquoi ça concerne presque toute
a population et pourquoi l'Asie orientale?
Eh bien la réponse, c'est peut-être
que les asiatiques ont été parmi
les premiers à "inventer l'alcool"
ou du moins à pratiquer la fermentation
alcoolique de façon maîtrisée,
on a en effet retrouvé en Chine des
traces de fabrication
de boissons alcoolisées datant
d'environ 9000 ans
et produites notamment par
la fermentation du riz,
c'est l'émergence de l'agriculture du riz
qui aurait favorisé
l'apparition des boissons alcoolisées,
or dans une publication parue en 2010,
des chercheurs chinois ont analysé
la fréquence des mutations de l'enzyme ADH
et ont cherché à les lier aux traces
archéologiques de domestication du riz.
Voici la carte qu'ils ont obtenu, on voit
en couleurs une estimation
de la fréquence des mutations,
pas loin de 100%
dans la zone la plus sombre
à l'est de la Chine
et les petits symboles en carré,
triangle et étoile
représentent divers sites archéologiques
montrant la domestication du riz.
Ce que cette publication suggère,
c'est que les mutations sont d'autant
plus fréquentes
dans les zones où l'agriculture du riz
est apparue
et où donc, les premières boissons
alcoolisées ont été produites.
Alors là c'est super bizarre ce qu'on
est en train de dire:
c'est parce qu'ils ont bu de l'alcool
avant les autres
que les populations de l'est de l'Asie
ont développé les mutations dont on a parlé?
Genre c'est l'alcool qui les a fait muter?
Eh ben en un certain sens oui!
Depuis le début de la vidéo j'ai quand
même passé sous silence
un élément essentiel concernant l'alcool,
les effets néfastes à long terme.
Alors on va quand même rappeler ça
vite fait,
il existe une grosse méta-analyse
qui couvre 195 pays et trois décennies
dont les données sont en accès libre,
donc vous pouvez aller les consulter,
je vous ai tracé quelques courbes
à partir de ça,
ici on voit par exemple l'évolution
du risque relatif de divers cancers
en fonction du nombre de verres quotidien,
alors oui, petit rappel:
la consommation d'alcool est cancérigène,
il s'agit même de la deuxième cause de
cancer après le tabac,
donc il faut le rappeler.
En abscisse dans le graphique, on parle
de ce qu'on appelle un verre standard:
un demi de bière, un verre de vin
ou un petit shot d'alcool fort,
ça revient à peu près au même en quantité
d'alcool, c'est un verre standard,
alors voici comment on lit ce graphique,
par exemple, si vous buvez 4 verres
par jour en moyenne,
eh bien votre risque de cancer des lèvres,
de la bouche, du pharynx est multiplié par 4,
et votre risque de cancer du larynx
ou de l’œsophage est multiplié par 2,
évidemment si vous buvez plus, eh bien
c'est beaucoup plus.
Voici le même graphique pour quelques
autres maladies,
alors attention, l'échelle verticale
est plus étendue,
sans surprise, ben l'alcool augmente
énormément le risque
de cirrhose, de pancréatite, mais
même de tuberculose,
et enfin il y a bien sûr tous les troubles
du comportement
associés à l'ivresse ou à la dépendance
à l'alcool,
violence envers soi-même ou envers
les autres,
blessures suite à des accidents domestiques
ou de transport,
et là, les augmentations de risque sont
quand même importantes.
Ce que ça montre, c'est qu'il y a 10
millions d'années, à l'époque du singe ivre,
c'était peut-être un avantage de pouvoir
consommer et métaboliser l'alcool,
mais que dans les sociétés humaines
actuelles,
eh bien le bénéfice de pouvoir boire de
l'alcool est quand même loin d'être évident.
Et donc ce qu'il a très bien pu se passer,
c'est que les mutations des enzymes
dont on a parlé ont empêché partiellement
la consommation d'alcool
chez les premiers humains qui les ont
développées,
manifestement d'abord en Asie orientale,
et du fait de leur consommation réduite
ou impossible,
ces individus ont eu un avantage évolutif,
une meilleure survie, un meilleur succès
reproductif,
et donc les mutations se sont répandues
dans les populations concernées.
On parle de sélection naturelle positive,
une manière de quantifier ça,
c'est de regarder
les troubles de la dépendance à l'alcool
dans les différentes régions,
et la façon dont elles se corrèlent
avec les mutations,
par exemple, dans cette étude réalisée à
Taiwan dans les années 90,
il a été montré que la version mutée
de l'enzyme ALDH
était beaucoup moins présente chez
les personnes présentant
une dépendance à l'alcool par rapport
ceux qui n'en présentaient pas,
et des résultats quasi identiques ont été
obtenus plus tard à Shanghai et au Japon.
En clair, si vous avez une ou plusieurs
des mutations dont on a parlé,
eh bien vous êtes moins à risque
de développer
un comportement addictif vis-à-vis
de l'alcool,
ça paraît logique hein, mais c'est bien de
voir les chiffres.
Et donc en conclusion, cette forme
d'intolérance à l'alcool
dont on parle depuis le début, eh ben
ça n'est pas une maladie
ou un défaut génétique, c'est même
le contraire,
c'est une évolution positive, une adaptation
qui a permis aux personnes porteuses
de ces mutations
d'améliorer leurs chances de survie.
Donc si vous faites partie des gens qui
tolèrent et qui consomment de l'alcool,
ben d'une part faites-le avec modération
en connaissant les risques,
je vous ai donné les chiffres, et surtout,
dans un contexte social,
évitez de stigmatiser les personnes
qui, par choix ou du fait de leur physiologie,
ne souhaitent pas boire d'alcool,
rappelez-vous
que c'est juste parce qu'ils sont un peu
en avance par rapport à vous
du point de vue de l'évolution.
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo, comme toujours,
j'ai un billet de blog
où je donne plus de références sur ces
histoires d'enzymes
et sur les articles scientifiques
que j'ai cités
et utilisés pour faire cette vidéo.
Si ce genre d'association entre génétique
et évolution culturelle vous intéresse,
j'avais aussi un épisode sur l'intolérance
au lactose,
pas tout à fait le même phénomène mais
très intéressant aussi.
Voilà, abonnez-vous, partagez la vidéo,
mettez la cloche pour ne rien rater des
prochaines publications,
et puis nous, on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo,
à bientôt.
[Musique]
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -